in eat yummy food moments hello foodies
of the Internet boy i'm nietzsche and
i'm katie and we are here to bring you
tasty tidbits tasty tidbits is a show
where we're gonna tell you all that's
going on in food today we've got a great
show for you including a special
appearance from Questlove try got to
interview him yeah you do
the Popeyes spicy chicken sandwich is
back and fans could not contain their
excitement it's inspired some pretty
crazy headlines including man pulls gun
on Popeyes employee for not having
enough chicken sandwiches Janelle Monae
suggested voter registration should be
at all Popeyes locations in Florida man
Beals wrath out of the aluminum foil
packaging of a chicken sandwich did that
really happen no my leg checks out for
them probably Florida yeah so we decided
to send our PA Mary Grace to the nearest
Popeyes so we could try the craze for
ourselves Oh Mary grace good luck Mary
grace so I was in and out of Popeyes in
less than an hour I'm actually very
pleasantly surprised I'm gonna bring
these back to the office and let's see
how these chicken steaks
thanks Mary grace now we're gonna send
this over to Matt our in-house taste
tester he digests all our food yes he
does Matt thanks Katie and Ichi thanks
Kitty and Ichi I actually tried to get
my hands on this sandwich before but
subsequently gave up so this is much
more convenient nice bun thick piece of
chicken
overall I'm really really sort of
impressed with this is a thick thick
piece of chicken it's got a really sort
of warm buttery bun some nice pickles in
there it's a little bit spicy but not
too spicy would I commit a crime for
this sandwich probably not but overall
it's a good chicken sandwich so back to
you Katie you Nicci hey Michi guess what
oh what's that Katie it's 2020 not yet
but almost which means it's almost the
end of a decade how terrifying I don't
think I did anything I definitely didn't
reach my goals but that's okay because
we're gonna talk about our favorite top
ten food moments of the decade audience
member it's our boss she just would
number ten Instagram yes we start our
countdown with our favorite place to
post all of our food pics it was created
in 2010 and you know what I just
realized Katie what Nietzsche it's the
grim as Jin Zee yeah it kind of is so
what if snapchat was just into the
groom's Instagram don't worry no you
guys remember getting crazy on Four Loko
I sure do one time that was it I
promised the caffeinated drink became
popular in 2010 when it was banned by
several universities everyone wants what
they can't have
but don't worry Nietzsche if you were
worried there's no for local for you
there still is they have in alcoholic
cell sir number a when we'd say Ryan
Gosling you think of one of two things
either hey girl
or you think of Ryan Gosling not eating
his cereal
that's our pick for number eight of our
favorite food moments of the decade
Wow I almost got started back of course
we know that in 2015 Ryan Gosling
finally did eat his cereal to honor the
memory of the vines creator Ryan at
McHenry and that's it for our food
moments of the decade for this tasty
tidbits tune in next week to find out
more Questlove thank you for joining us
on tasty tidbit we're here to talk about
your new cookbook
yes mixtape potluck it's super fun I
love all the art in it it's very kind of
retro thank you what is your
recommendation to make it like the best
Pollock ever the best potluck is where
people just bring the basics they feel
like they have to kill the game like
some super wave thing I've seen people
get their feelings hurt we're
particularly chilly from their grand
moms like recipe from long ago was
neglected because everyone just ate all
the nachos and rice you right simple I'm
the guy that will bring the Forgotten
things like there's never enough hot
sauce there's never enough ice there's
never enough good music so I I provide
the atmosphere that brings it up to the
next level so are you always like the
guy on the playlist every week I come up
with a new challenge on what 100 songs
will fit this particular mood Oh have
you ever eaten something so good that
you had to go write a song or some music
after it the reason why I got into this
game in the first place was to do that
exactly the roots wanted to change the
narrative of what Philadelphia was in
the music world so we figured the best
way to fold together the resources of
the Philadelphia music community was
free food then of course that juin all
the musicians that I wanted to come over
then was like oh by the way guys
here's some instruments let's write so
we were like just lure them in so a
potluck is basically like a jam food it
is the best social adhesive ever that's
what brings people together
I agree hey me too a lot of people know
that here at tasty we have a full
culinary team that tests every recipe we
make yeah they're professional and it
really
so we're introducing a new segment we
call who it's cooking
[Music]
situation Oh
this how we find out flavor Bigfoot
right a recipe this one I sprayed let's
try that
oh yes boom if it was clear it's gonna
be clear what was supposed to happen
here in 2020
oh that's 2020 typography typography you
can see how some of the pieces were
maybe breaking off and floating around
so the team is starting filming right
now as you can see behind me they're
kind of planning their shoot for the
2020 cake
all right great so cool we're going to
cut to a top-down and you're just gonna
finish taking
[Music]
wow this 20/20 cake is exactly what I
need in my life
thanks for bringing some back I love
carbs yes absolutely it was the perfect
time of year nobody cares Michael it's
all good nobody cares about car January
we care about carbs mm-hmm and thanks
for hanging out with us I'm Nietzsche
okay and this has been a fun time oh yes